Canadian police have broken up protests
against coronavirus restrictions,
which had been blocking an important trade
route with the US. A blockade of trucks and
cars had stopped the flow of commerce
across the Ambassador Bridge - North
America's busiest border crossing. But
demonstrators at a larger protest are
still occupying parts of the Canadian capital
Ottawa - to the annoyance of local residents.
Canada's busiest border crossing is getting ready
to re-open. After a week-long standoff at the
Ambassador Bridge, police in Windsor, Ontario,
have arrested dozens of protesters and cleared
away vehicles that had blocked the vital highway.
Yeah, I`m frustrated that we're on day seven of
this. I mean this, I could have told you from
the first hour that this is not going to end
well unless we get in there and cut the head off
the snake very, very quickly. This is a crucial
border crossing. We're talking about $400 million
a day that crosses at this one border crossing. So
the financial impact, you know, to now is nearing
$3 billion on our national economy. That's huge.
The situation in Canada's capital, Ottawa, remains
far from resolved. Trucks block the city center
and protesters camp out in front of Parliament.
Residents have had enough.
You're not free to go
anywhere you want in your city. I mean, there's
an illegal occupation happening. The rule of
law doesn't exist a few blocks away. So
I mean, it's I guess it's intimidating.
Police have been reluctant to clear out protesters
as long as there are children with them.
Well, there's children here, and unfortunately,
parents are using their children, so
I don't know. It's a really tough
situation for the police because,
you know, violence should not happen. So and,
I, the police are in a really tough situation.
Canada's Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
has told protesters it's time to go home.
They don't seem to be listening.